[Music]
before we start this video i just want
to mention that only 20.7 percent of you
are subscribed if you enjoy the content
don't forget to like and subscribe to
support the channel thanks hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory today we're going to be
discussing for the sixth time the events
that transpired in the harry potter
universe after the books and films ended
i have now made five separate videos on
this topic to date parts one two three
four and five which each cover ten
separate characters and what they got up
to opposed to deathly hallows between
those five videos i've managed to cover
voldemort neville hermione ron harry
george luna hagrid draco the dursleys
umbridge fudge lockhart flitwick filch
ollivander kingsley shacklebolt pomona
sprout arthur molly weasley percy
weasley aberforth dumbledore fleur
seamus finnegan mcgonagall narcissa
lucius cormac mclagan group rita skeeter
slughorn dean thomas charlie weasley
sybil trelawny varenze oliver wood
madame maxime bill weasley pansy
parkinson aunt marge patil twins
ginny weasley newt scamander cho chang
andromeda tonks moaning myrtle
xenophilius lovegood katie bell bane
winky poppy pomfrey and montangus
fletcher and i'm not stopping today i'm
going to be continuing that trend and
giving you part six of what happened to
these ten characters after the war
i'll link parts one two three four and
five in the pinned comment i've got just
enough characters left for part seven as
well so keep an eye out for that in the
near future
without further ado let's dive into the
lives of 10 characters post war and post
deathly hallows 1. rolanda hooch
rolanda or madame hooch is a british
witch was speculated to have been born
sometime before the year 1918.
there isn't that much information
available on her and she doesn't appear
in the books or films very much however
she is very important in that she is the
one responsible for teaching the
students their foundational knowledge of
flying broomsticks
not only that but madam hooch is a
quidditch referee an aerial sport
really a whole world revolves around
flying which is why it shouldn't
surprise you that after the war had
ended madame hooch simply returned to
her post at hogwarts where she continued
to teach flying and referee quidditch
for many years to come
2. alphaius doge el firestoge is a
british pureblood wizard born in either
1880 or 1881
notably doge was a close friend of
dumbledore their friendship blossoming
during their schoolboy years
while at hogwarts doge came down with a
bad case of dragon pox causing everyone
to avoid him
except of course for dumbledore elphaas
was an active member of the order of the
phoenix in both wars and the ministry of
magic jurist poison peace specialist
rita skeeter would often refer to doge
as dimwitted however that's likely only
due to his lack of cooperation during
the writing of skeeter's magnum opus the
life and lies of albus dumbledore in
fact doge a special advisor to the
wizard gamut was quite the opposite of
dimwitted and lived out the rest of his
days serving the british ministry for
magic arguing with great aunt muriel and
missing his dear friend albus dumbledore
3. creature creature was a male house
elf born in an unknown year who loyally
served at the house of black for the
majority of his life
that is until he was left with harry
potter after the death of sirius before
this however creature was known to be
fiercely loyal to sirius's brother
regulus who he shared a special bond
with
after the death of regulus creature was
a bit lost never learning to properly
respect his new master sirius
however creature did eventually come to
respect harry who treated him extremely
well
during the battle of hogwarts creature
led the house elves into the fray
against lord voldemort and his followers
creature ended up surviving the battle
and from that point entered into
full-time service of the potter family
in 2017 jk rowling revealed the creature
did eventually die at the tender age of
666
where he was at that time is anyone's
guess
4. victor crum
victor crumb is a bulgarian wizard born
in 1976
perhaps best known for competing against
harry vler and cedric in the tri-wizard
tournament representing his school
durmstrang
crum was an exceptionally gifted
quidditch player and was the seeker for
the bulgarian national quidditch team at
the tender age of 18. in 1994 he played
in the final of the quidditch world cup
and he was still just a student
crumb continued to play quidditch for
many years before his eventual
retirement following the bulgarian
team's defeat in the 2002 world cup
final however this retirement didn't
last long as crum came out of retirement
to compete in the 2014 world cup
famously the bulgarian team won that
year's cup beating out brazil in the
finals
crum retired a true quidditch legend 5.
john daulish john daulish is a british
pure blood wizard and ministry of magic
employee who served the institution as
an aura
for most of his career daulish worked
directly underneath cornelius fudge
accompanying him on various assignments
daulish would also later work for
ministers rufus krimga and pius
thickness daulish failed quite a few
assignments towards the end of the
second wizarding war the most likely
reason being that he repeatedly faced
far superior opponents dumbledore
unfamiliar situations hagrid being a
half-giant and continual placement under
the confunder's charm not much is known
of what happened to dawlish following
the war but we do know that he survived
and that he continued to act not quite
right for some time after most likely
due to his repeated subjection to the
confundus charm it's unlikely that
dawlish was charged as a sympathizer of
voldemort and it's entirely probable
that due to his brain damage he ended up
in saint mangoes
6. blaise zabini
blaise sabini was a pureblood wizard
that attended hogwarts around the same
time as harry potter he was a member of
slytherin house and was on good terms
with draco malfoy and his gang blaise
was a quiet boy that mostly kept to
himself
but on occasion would express his
extreme prejudice towards muggles
muggleborns and blood traitors
no one knows exactly what happened to
blaise post-war but we do know that he
probably survived as most southern
students sat the battle out
given that blaze were skilled in potion
making progressing to the newt level in
the subject it's entirely possible that
he pursued a career in potions 7. mrs
figg mrs figg aka arabella doreen figg
was a squib that lived near harry
potter's childhood home on privet drive
the dursey residence given that she
lived down the street from harry she
would commonly babysit him
simultaneously helping to keep an eye on
him for albus dumbledore though mrs figg
did whatever she could to help the order
and good guys as a squib it's unlikely
that she participated in the battle of
hogwarts
it wouldn't have been safe for her there
given her affinity for furry feline
companions i like to imagine that mrs
figg lived out the rest of her days
crossbreeding and trading part measle
cats 8. marcus flint marcus flint was a
pureblood wizard born in 1976 whose
family name appeared on the sacred 28 a
list of 28 pureblood wizarding families
he attended hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry from 1987 to
1994
and notably served as captain of the
southern quidditch team from at least
1991 to 1994.
flint was one of harry's quidditch
rivals
no one knows what happened to marcus
flint but given his affinity for the
mockery of others and inability to play
nice i doubt he got far there's always
the possibility he became a professional
quidditch player but i personally don't
think that any teams would have welcomed
him on board
9. ernie mcmillan ernie mcmillan was a
pure blood wizard who attended hogwarts
during the same years as harry potter
notably ernie was the one who suspected
that harry potter was the heir of
slytherin during the opening of the
chamber of secrets in his second year
that is until hermione was petrified and
ernie changed his mind later apologizing
to harry ernie survived the battle of
hogwarts but not much is known of his
later life i like to imagine that he
stayed in touch with his good friends
hannah abbott and justin finch fletchley
which would also put him in neville's
social circle given that hannah was
married to neville 10. crookshanks
crookshanks was hermione's half-nasal
pet cat that she purchased from magical
menagerie in 1993.
crookshanks was a particularly
intelligent cat helping to expose peter
pettigrew as scabbers
though crookshanks is very cute and
highly intelligent it's unlikely that he
would have been much help during the
final battle of the war
so instead he stayed at the home of the
weasleys the borough waiting things out
until everything had settled down
he was later reunited with hermione
given that crookshanks was just a cat in
a pet store that apparently nobody
wanted he really did make quite an
impact on the story and that's it for
this video who next who have i missed
leave a comment down below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
you